all right thumbnail time you ready
wait the same
same have
scream five well we gotta change that up
left hand here we go
perfect
[Music]
so Scream Six is the sixth film in the
scream franchise a horror movie
franchise which has been going strong
for far longer than I ever thought
possible especially after the passing of
the late great West Craven in this
installment Ghostface comes to Manhattan
that's right because we he hasn't come
to Manhattan he's done college campus
he's taken LA but not New York and we
have ourselves something that feels new
different there's never been one like me
Gail this isn't like any other ghost
face just like the last one felt
different something about this one just
feels different right out the gate
though I will say you know how there's
always a ghost face killing at the
beginning this has something that
the scene ended where I was like I
haven't seen that in a Scream movie
I am interested I perked up in my chair
it was familiar but a new take on the
familiar it piqued my curiosity and I
was in it for this film this movie
expands as a sequel should but the soul
the heart and soul of scream doesn't get
lost in that expansion it uses these new
locations in fun ways the world feels
bigger but it still screamed to its core
all work to continue in this film what
the previous film had which was a ghost
face that's very menacing one can say
almost angry I suppose it comes down to
efficiency Ghostface feels like a more
efficient killer first three Scream
movies he's tripping over people he's
getting refrigerator doors slammed in
his face when it's clearly coming the
counter argument is well it's hard to
see out of the Mask guess it's been
figured out new mesh technology in the
eyepiece is because he never comes
across as bumbling in here comes across
as a menacing badass with perfect 20 20
Vision who will shotgun you in the face
with your own shotgun Ghost Face
killings are Savage they're bloody
they're violent they're angry also this
is probably the most anxiety in due sing
scream film of all of them that cat and
mouse game that goes on in certain
scenes like that Subway scene you saw in
the trailer there are a couple others
which it brings you to a simmer just
boils you just keeps you there like all
right we're just gonna keep you here for
a few solid minutes no time for rest
your heart's just beating out of your
[__] chest the entire time I'm like
dude I need a minute that was awesome
that's when this movie was doing it
right I loved feeling like I love that
this movie gave me that Hayden
panettier's back I appreciate the fact
that she is back because Kirby and
Scream 4 was a standout character she
died but we didn't see her technically
die it was that leeway of like okay if
if you can bring her back that'd be
great also she works how they
Incorporated her into the story I like
that she was back and I appreciated that
they made it work that she was back it
didn't feel forced I mean not forced for
a scream film anyway it's some of these
things start feeling like it's a very
small world out there an actress who is
not back is Nev Campbell as Sydney
Prescott she's not in this movie I'm of
two minds of it on one hand if you want
to keep making Scream movies you can't
have ghost face coming after Sydney all
the time and if Ghostface is coming
after someone new you can't have Sydney
just butt in and be like hi I'm here
obviously I'm the most qualified right
at what point is she just gonna live her
life on the other hand that's not the
reason she's not in it it was a paid
dispute I think they should have paid
Nev Campbell whatever money she wanted
because I feel like she's earned it for
scream Courtney Cox as Gail weathers is
back though her role in here does kind
of seem redundant so I'm glad that I
don't feel that for Sydney now with Nev
Campbell gone it falls on Jenna Ortega
and Melissa Barrera to carry this film
granted they were the leads in the
previous movie as well but in a world
where the studio didn't pay Nev Campbell
Nev Campbell didn't come back it would
have been easy to have the vibe of
scream doesn't work without Nev Campbell
and I don't mind saying it's most Alyssa
Barrera and Jenna Ortega who make it
work but the thing that was most
annoying in this film there are
instances in here where people get
stabbed should die but they just don't
some of them just don't die some of them
are just up and running around in the
next scene I'm like how is that though
and it comes across like they are afraid
to kill characters in this film and I
shouldn't feel like that in a Scream
movie it doesn't always happen there are
people who bite it absolutely but it
happens enough for me to feel like they
are afraid to kill characters it all
depends on what you want out of a scream
film what you're accustomed to getting
out of a scream film celebration of
horror check menacing Ghostface double
check gory bloody kills absolutely
celebration of scream also there because
you're not just celebrating horror
movies now it's a sixth installment of
scream so now you have scream
celebration as well all wrapped up in a
new location in the big city that lends
for new possibilities and you feel that
kind of scope I had myself a good time
no alcohol required alright so Scream
Six have you seen it what did you think
about it if you have have what's your
screen order order from best to worst
the new screen movie so it's in there
somewhere your list this time will be
different than the last time so I'm
pretty sure I asked that last time
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
foreign